si choisir c'est renoncer et dylan
collet a choisi de ne pas renoncer entre
le vélo et la musique ce chef
d'orchestre unit ces deux passions et
comme à son habitude c'est un vélo qu'il
rejoint la prochaine ville où il joue ce
dimanche
là je concerte avec l'orchestra net
je trouve ça sympa de rouler avec les
futurs spectateurs
merci les gars à peine le temps d'être
célébré par ses hôtes d'un soir qu'il
faut déjà filé pour la répétition
comique orchestra le nom du spectacle
c'est la rencontre entre l'opéra de
tours est le chef d'orchestre dylan
corlay sous sa baguette musiciens et
spectateurs se retrouvent autour d'un
répertoire classique avec des
arrangements improbable
[Musique]
c'est confiance aux musiciens
d'orchestre comme un public pour un
partage qui n'existe nulle part ailleurs
que c'est pas moi c'est un génie je
trouve qu'il a énormément de travail
derrière tout ce qui fait même si on a
l'impression que c'est super naturel et
c'est un travail de dingue c'est c'est
tout est pensé de a à z et nous et ben
on est juste les interprètes de ça et
c'est une chance énorme de faire ça
voilà
issue d'un parcours académique des plus
exigeants le chef d'orchestre est un
touche-à-tout piano harmonica claquettes
champ sur scène il ne s'interdit rien on
peut dire que c'est un spectacle
atypique dans le sens où
c'est rare de voir un orchestre
symphonique comme ça qui est mis en
scène
réellement c'est à dire il n'est pas là
pour accompagner quelque chose il y là
son vrai rôle y lave c'est un personnage
l' orchestre un personnage et j'ai un
personnage du coup c'est un vrai duo
on expérimente on se lance des petits
défis ou communicants fait pas par la
parole mais par justement par des petits
objets par par les sons par la musique
encore faut-il arriver à l'heure sur
scène on vous laisse le spectacle va
commencer
[Musique]